pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
bonjour à toutes les épis curieuse et
tous les hippies curieux aujourd'hui
c'est mercredi comme chaque mercredi je
réponds aux questions que vous m'avez
posé avec le hashtag dit jeannot une
question de rigueur à propos des
cucurbitacées la citrouille et tel un
fruit ou un légume alors d'un point de
vue botanique la citrouille est un fruit
tout simplement parce qu elle se forme à
partir d'une fleur comme la tomate
d'ailleurs la prune ou la cerise mais
d'un point de vue culinaire on parle de
la citrouille comme d'un légume parce
qu'on ne la consomme pas en dessert mais
plutôt en soupe
du reste on trouve les citrouilles dans
les potagers
alors que les fruits oeufs sont récoltés
dans les vergers une question de majin
concernant la vidéo sur les feuilles
d'automne j'ai un arbre chez moi qui
jaunit mais dont les feuilles ne tombe
pas pourquoi alors c'est effectivement
le cas de certains arbres et arbustes re
comme le charme ou le renaudin drones
ont dit que ces arbres sont mars et sans
alors ça ne signifie pas et que les
feuilles ne tombe pas le charme par
exemple pas garder ses feuilles flétries
pendant tout l'hiver c'est la saison du
repos végétatif
mais elles vont finir par tomber au
printemps quand les nouvelles feuilles
vont repousser les nouvelles vont
pousser des anciennes une question date
hawks sur la vidéo démarre et si le
soleil la lune et la terre sont alignés
pourquoi n'assistons pas à une éclipse
alors quand la terre la lune et le
soleil sont alignés on assiste à une
marées de vives-eaux cet alignement
correspondent effectivement à celui
d'une éclipse
mais pour que celle ci ait lieu la lune
doit se trouver dans ce qu'on appelle le
plan de l'écliptique c'est à dire le
plan dans lequel la terre tourne autour
du soleil
si elles se trouvent un peu au dessus ou
un peu au dessous ce qui se produit la
plupart du temps il n'ya pas wikileaks
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche